things on thursday so we begin with
mr lavrov's schedule
and we're going to speak about our
delegations
work in new york its participation in
the
uh session of the
general assembly we have already
announced our delegations participations
and the main ideas that we're going to
get across
as well as the main concept of the work
that we are going to follow at this
international forum
i would like also to add that
mr lavrov's schedule
is being worked on now since we are
receiving many requests
to participate in both bilateral and
multilateral meetings but as of today i
can say that
we have planned about 25 meetings with
the heads of
other countries delegations and the
meeting with the
u.n secretary general
as well as the president of the 76th
session of the u.n general assembly
there are going to be some
multilateral
meetings and
is going to speak as well at the
um
general debate over the
general assembly and he's going to
hold a press conference for the
journalists accredited at this
international
forum
i would like also to note that
this yeah the pandemic is still in place
and for this reason
as the schedules can be somehow adjusted
and we're going to announce all the
meetings that are going to take place
although i cannot say for sure
what meetings and
when
mr lavrov is going to have
since we have got some questions
about the meetings and we have been
asked to confirm some of them
there are going to be some negotiations
between mr lavrov and his counterparts
from egypt syria slovakia poland
france
is going to meet the minister of foreign
affairs of
the united kingdom cuba
but i would like to
point out once again that
these are just the meetings that we are
planning but there are going to be
more of them
so we are going to keep you posted on
that
and now i'm moving to
some
meetings that will definitely take place
uh on the 27th of september mr lavrov is
going to meet the minister of foreign
affairs of the socialist republic of
vietnam um
as part of his first official visit to
russia as the head of the
foreign
minister of fornication he is going to
discuss the pressing issues of the
bilateral agenda and the key aspects of
interaction within regional and
international organizations and forum
and on the 28th of september mr lavrov
is going to participate in the business
council uh under the
minister of foreign fires of the russian
federation and
the meeting will be devoted to
discussing the new trends and priorities
of the international interaction
within the current international climate
agenda
the event will bring together the
relevant russian
ministries and agencies
the company is concerned and
business community
this business council was established in
2006 and it
is mainly tasked with strengthening
cooperation with the russian business um
and the protection of political and
economic interests of our countries
abroad uh the using of the potential of
the minister of foreign affairs and
russian foreign
offices abroad to support the foreign
economic activity
and on the 2nd of october mr lavrov will
participate in the work of the
assembly of the council on foreign and
defense policy i would like to remind
you that this is russia's oldest
non-governmental organization it's an
expert an intellectual club bringing
together the experts in the sphere of
international uh relations and foreign
policy
it will devoted to the following it is
actually titled
um
is there any ideas where is russia going
amid the drastic and national changes
and the ministers going to share the
views on the current stage of
international development and the
foreign political tasks that our country
has and ways to
fulfill them
and there's going to be an interactive
discussion that mr lavrov is going to
participate and such a form of
discussion will allow to
inform of
the russian approaches to the current
issues on the international agenda and
get a feedback
sometimes useful criticism and the
minister foreign affairs of the russian
federation highly values the current
level and the quality of dialogue
between the expert community and
attaches much attention uh and abundance
to it
now to the
to the international agenda and i would
like to say a few words about the
election to the state duma we have
already come up with the comments and in
real time you
had an opportunity to monitor the voting
that
took place in many
russian foreign
offices and missions
sometimes
you didn't manage to follow it in real
time
but still now we can
make some conclusions
um the russian minister of foreign
affairs
tallied the votes yesterday
and actually
the
election took place
in all the bowling stations
which totaled
348 the turnout was 192
uh just for comparison and by the way we
had a question about that uh we were
asked to
provide statistics
so this is what i'm doing now in 2 2016.
the turnout was
and during the presidential election in
474 thousand
but i would like to point out the main
comparison
between all those
elections
now
the election is taking place
under special circumstances which is the
pandemic so despite the pandemic the
russian foreign missions
fulfilled
the task and
the election once again i would like to
stress this
was a transparent and open and
this was evident to everyone both to the
observers to the broad public to the
journalists
and by the way we have published
the materials in real time
the election
were held in full compliance with the
law on legislation uh with the
unnecessary security measures and in
some countries like in the netherlands
in the united states in houston for
example people tick to the streets
who supported the so-called russian
non-systemic opposition but
despite that this did not affect
uh the
work of the polling stations i'm not
talking about ukraine now it's a common
place already
but so everything
[Music]
went on routinely and uh
back in 2020
we had this um situation as well uh it
is connected with julia illionska
who drew attention to herself having
cast two ballots
in the town of azde israel despite the
fact that she signed
the
paper saying that she has been informed
that she could fight face administrative
and criminal charges if she uh violates
the law
uh but there were no other provocative
actions that we have fixed
um the only thing i can say is that
in the czech republic
photos have been spread
um
with the
polling stations on them um they thought
to be quite high profile but actually
there was nothing like that our
embassies
just got the necessary material on how
to prevent the cases
of
people cast into ballots
so there were no
threats security threats to the russian
foreign missions
and the election
were monitored by many observers
ranging from
the political parties and candidates to
deputies and the public chamber of the
russian federation
there were some insignificant claims
they have been considered and the
explanations were given
there were some misunderstandings
related to
the observers from yablaco party
many of whom attended the election
unofficially since the applications to
the territorial polling stations expired
international observers in particular
the cia center parliamentary assembly
representatives attended the polling
stations and
we received
no
comments
whatsoever as for the protocols and the
tallies
the materials about that have been
given to the central electoral
commission so if you have any questions
please address them
i cannot mention the response from our
foreign partners
from the foreign partners
representing the collective west so to
say we have already commented on that by
the way in real life in real time
so we have just received the statements
of the state department of the united
states they
could not but
write something about the election
so the state department of the united
states as we expected
um
was concerned with our countries
fulfilling its obligations within the oc
and
we can point out that the americans
were quite fast to join the inverted
rusev hobbs from the european parliament
and
it was not a it was not too clear who
joined whom
but still
it is for the experts
to look into that
but i would like to
point out that the final results of the
election were not
published yet
so i would like to remind you that the
election
took place in full compliance with
the russian legislations and the norms
of international law
and despite the unprecedented
number of cyber attacks against the
russian central electoral commission
which the central electoral commission
mentioned and half of
these attacks
were from the united
states and the blatant interference of
the american internet platforms in the
preparations and
holding of the election
and the our
foes did manage to discredit the russian
electoral system and they will not be
able to do that and washington by
tradition
doesn't bother to
provide some concrete facts
to you know to
make the insinuations more substantiated
and at the same time it
declares its
interest in a constructive dialogue
so
it's
either
a constructive dialogue or
um
uh some democracy so uh it is for you to
decide
um and we are much interested in the
material
um
of interference
coming from the united states so if you
have some material please send us
we
welcome
the
resumption of the work of the
international airport in kabul it
creates positive conditions for
people coming back to normal life and
it
it implies that the situation in
afghanistan
is coming back to normal
and the
social and economic situation
is becoming more stable
and
the head of the w cho mr gabriel
is going to
make a visit to kabul
so we will keep you posted on that as
well
today we got a breaking news
that
concerned everyone here
and it is about carter against versus
russia
kais
so
the judgment passed by the european
court of human rights related to the
complaint filed by litvinenko's widow on
the 21st of september raises many
questions about the findings of the
court the ruling of the court
its procedure and approaches
we can see that the european court of
human rights which position itself as
international
court
still tries to apply political role and
contribute to
paddling of russophobia that has gained
traction in many western states
and we cannot understand why it has
taken the position of rubbish stumping
the findings of the national legal body
um of
the
council of
europe member states uh which are
apparently politicized and dubious
uh so if we do not look uh to the
content of the document and uh
quite spurious findings
of the european court of human rights
we cannot but
note
the arbitrary departure of its own
practice so when it comes to individual
complaints
related to interstate disputes
so before that
the european court of human rights
bound itself to refrain from considered
such cases before it passes judgments on
the key issues within the
related interstate
motion so i would like to remind you
that on the 23rd of february 2021
ukraine filed the ninth complaint
against russia
related to targeted assassinations of
people
who are perceived as opponents to russia
in russia or on the territory of other
states so
since
the complaint
called litvinenko versus russia against
russia
falls under the category of this
interstate
complaint
raises our concern and
we have a plex to with that since the
court is quite inconsistent
because it should have suspended its
consideration and we reckon uh without
the turnability of caves complain from
the point of view of the law and within
it inadmissible that the european court
has taken different approaches and
similar cases
and a few words about the
item related to catalonia in the
resolution of the european parliament on
russia on the 16th of september the
european parliament approved the
resolution uh which brought up the
question about a sensible
connection between the catalonian
separatists and russia the only ground
for
form
um writing uh about this
uh was actually a recent
new york times fake article paddled by
the spanish mass media and by the way
the
majority of the
parliamentarians
ignored the position of the spanish
national court
and
by the way it was indeed a fake news we
asked
the new york times to publish
the rebuttal
so
we are still waiting for that to come
so we'll continue the spanish national
court
dismissed the case
awaiting to a lack of evidence
since
there was no interference on the part of
russia to
the referendum on the catalonian
self-determination
the same is true for the prosecutor
general's office of spain
that
found
the investigation into the so-called
russian trace
uh futile and unsubstantiated well you
know it's absurd
they have used the material of the new
york times
article
so it
adopts a resolution on the basis of a
new york's time new york times
article
disregarding
the
judgment made by the
spanish national court
itself
so it's not even louise carroll's
works it's
um
it's like
it's an asylum or
even worse
like a circus
with
with the new
documents
which are indeed the fake
i spread on and on
who is to bear the responsibility within
its body
for
some basic fact checking
checking of data and information that
are going to be used
we believe that the european bodies
have long been using
the following rule
if it's about criticizing russia
everything can be acceptable
any
lie
but people
who are in the european parliament
represent both themselves the
lobby groups
they in fact represent
the peoples
of different countries
but
de facto they do not represent them but
they set them up
by
thinking up such absurd things
i would like to remind you that it was
one of
the eu member states
namely belgium
granted asylum to the fugitive
leaders of the catalonian separatism
and it denied
the extradition to madrid i cannot
recall
that the european parliament would
consider
uh these uh very issues
i cannot say that we insist on that but
there should be some logic
behind all this
it
can be false logic but
it is still logic
but here we can see no logic at all
we would like to point out once again
that we have
voiced russia's official position
uh which
is that
the situation in catalonia is
spain's
affair exclusively and
we assume that in our relations with
spain this should be done
in line with respect for sovereignty and
territorial integrity of this country
we also paid attention to the foreign
media
publications
which was
prepared by
high officials
and also in the statements of the
nato
officials during
different kind of events
including on the 17th 19th of september
during the meeting of the chiefs of
staff
they discussed the the
military exercises of the zapat west
2021 were not in line with the criterion
of the vienna document on confidence
building and security building measures
the uh
a accusing us of many things of
concealing the data of providing
irrelevant information and they have
many claims and blames
so how can we call it uh this is a
distortion of the truth or is it a
misleading information
we have already confirmed that russia
is fully in line with its obligations
according to the vienna document and
provides the high level of transparency
as well as in its territory as well as
during the events with our allies the
russian federation
has become the most verified according
to the vienna document of
2011.
i would like to stress once again that
we
have already uh briefed our partners
about their military exercises west 2021
we've already talked about it but it was
uh done
by the ministers of the defense of
russian and belarus and moscow and the
minsk and during the forum for security
cooperation in vienna and the parameters
and the order of the maneuvers were
observed in the media and we also
invited
military diplomats as observers how
could we
do
more
for our western partners to come down
and we'd like to stress that the maximum
quantity of the military personnel
according to the vienna document in the
territory of russia didn't exceed 6 400
persons which is
more
inferior to the notification threshold
of the military activities under the
document who tried to raise doubts about
this number
i should once again read the vienna
document of
on the fact what categories are covered
by it and uh those are not
so we'd like to talk
in detail about that
nato has long
been for the practice of dividing the
military exercises in stages in order to
prevent
and to evade the notification thresholds
they have the same operative concept
context and
they are carried out with their native
forces and u.s armed forces
who are involved in these exercises and
as
for the major maneuvers
led by the united states which were held
in may arjuna this year
with the participation of 16 states from
the
baltic states to the balkans in the
south
and our
observers were not invited there
as uh for the statements
of the innate representatives about the
necessity to modernize the vienna
document they are far far from reality
because these documents was signed and
renewed in different military
circumstances and now through the
process of the vienna document the
alliance
it seems
strange to compensate the information
losses that became the result of the
suspension of a cfe
treaty on conventional armed forces in
europe and
providing
the unilateral scanning
of the activities of the rational armed
forces
we
do not
okay with this kind of modernization in
the line of containing our country
and
passing to
the topic that
we are planning to highlight in detail
in the future
but i will
talk on it briefly on the 1st of october
it
will be
the
75th anniversary of the work of the
nuremberg tribunal
on the 1st of october 1946
a judicial process was finalized in
nuremberg it became known as the
international military tribunal people's
court which formalized the final defeat
of the fascism it was one of the
major political and
legal outcomes of
the defeat of the nazis germany
we can not our state
it's important for the mankind
and the first time in history this kind
of aggressive policies were qualified as
a criminal offences against humanity
and
there was a
and the genocide was
legally defined and the
persons perpetrators of the
atrocities were brought to justice
in no way this process was not a venture
to the
german people that were
also
taking refuge by the hitler's policy
so the
allies of the anti-hitler coalition were
unanimous you know the outcomes and the
nuremberg process affected much of the
practice of international law and their
conceptual decisions
which were taken by the united nations
as their principles of after were
international humanitarian and criminal
law
uh solutions
remain political and legally relevant
the verdict of the nuremberg tribunal
is
still valid when there are attempts to
rewrite the outcomes of the second world
war
to equalize the aggressors and the
liberators of the victims at the
executors and to make heroes out of the
criminal perpetrators
it is uh an admissible to write the
history of the second world war to
justify the nazis the accomplices and
the atrocities so the historical
importance of the new england process is
never-ending and its outcomes should not
be rewrited
rewritten
the second
world war
as you know will be also discussed in
the topic of
the russian
uh
signing now the decree
uh to about the one-time payment or to
the citizens of the russian federation
awarded with the medals of medals so for
of the defense of the leningrad and to
assign
a citizen of the besieged leningrad this
is a tribute to the courage and
terrorism of the residents of our
leningrad and it is a widely uh symbolic
you know the year of for the 18th
anniversary of
the
attack brutal attack of the
fascist germany against the ussr and we
have many times
urged our german partners who carried
out the humanitarian and other kinds of
payments exclusively
to the jewish
people
and now in the 21st century it's very
hard even to pronounce these facts
when we see the division of one
nationality from the other when we speak
about such con events but we have to
know to
take note of these facts
and so we urged our
german partners
who have already
given payments to the
jewish victims
not to
draw distinctions between the peoples
who equally uh suffered from those
events and we have already stressed that
berlin should
take
decisions on the principles of
non-discrimination adjusted as
moral values without attempts to
cover with a pseudo
legal pretext but
our attempts
were not responded positively and we
would leave it to the conscious of those
who have taken such decisions
as for the
actions of the russian federation you
know everything and i've already
reminded of you of them another topic is
the situation in
the freedom of the media in ukraine and
the situation is still degrading and the
kiev authorities
is trying to mob its information space
from other mass media outlets
which uh
view is descending from the ukrainian
standards
and another victims
were nash
365 inter and first independent
channels
and
some
licenses have revoked
that
could lead to total blockage in the
satellite channels and retransmission
channels inter would be
subject to unscheduled checks for
non absence of the language quotes and
the demonstration of our soviet uh
of movies with the participation of the
actors actors
which
is a threat to national security of
ukraine and
first independent channel
was also monitored by the
security service of ukraine and
it was formed on the remnants of other
uh tv channels as one
one two uh ukraine zika and then used to
and
they are not concealing that such
phenomena uh would be a usual for uh
these uh
for this uh
country
and this is a
really magical kind of democration that
we see in europe
and we are also concerned by the
information
dictatorship that has not been
refuted
by
the heads of uh states who are still uh
considered the supervisor supervisors of
the freedom of speech in ukraine and at
the same time
who are
considered
the sponsors of
the
settlement of the intra ukrainian crisis
and the international uh bodies are also
silent
they do not have times and seems because
they are very engaged in
settling the situation our country
and
on the 14th of uh september they open
a letter of the journalists that were
centered to
the
secretary and secretary general young
high commissioner for our human rights
and special rapporteur
on for freedom of opinion and expression
spokesperson of the office of then for
human rights
this letter were
went unnoticed
and the
correspondence who
in kiev who also
sent a as a requester to president of
the united states uh biden
also
were unnoticed or
was ignored and we urged international
institutions including the osce
institutions on the freedom of the new
media unesco
to give a
assessment of the situation in on
the in the field of the india
freedom in ukraine and we also
uh re urge the ukrainian authorities
to stop uh their persecution of the
journalism and to stop uh destroying the
pluralism of our views
now i'm giving the floor to the
journalist
yes
vishnikova
i would like to ask you for your
questions so now we have a
in
information about the third suspect on
this cripples case how could you comment
on this london
says that
this is a representative of the russian
intelligence service
like also to ask what uh
mr lavrov would do with his mandatory
for the diabetes seat
let's start for with the second
question i've already mentioned it
but i would like to
highlight once again that the outcomes
of
of the
elections were not
uh officially announced and we have to
wait up for the results according to the
procedure as uh for your second
question yes i've already seen this
scotland yard
information about the
bringing charges against our
citizens in absentia
and we
have already commented on the topic
but
we do not know why we're still
discussing it maybe this is about the
the planning uh that is being untaken by
london to prepare for
the
meeting of our foreign ministers
but i would like to
note that about uh for over 10 years
that the british authorities are using
this incident in salisbury for
complicating our bilateral relations in
spite of our
multiple requests
and our urges to the
dialogue
london refuses to collectively
investigate this incident where
our russian citizens were affected and
the british authorities neglect their
obligations under the consular
conventions of 1965
and the authorities of the great britain
use the skripals as
an instrument for influencing our
country and for heating up anti-russian
spirits in the society
and using such tactics in the media
outlets we
condemn all this uh shifting the plane
blame of our british colleagues
and we urge them to
and
carry out unbiased investigation
and to to involve of the relevant
aspects in
the
proceedings
we
are in favor for the objective
investigation and our position is still
intact and we are willing to
establish the truth
and we will still demand
that the british authorities would
comply with its obligations
while providing the consular access to
our citizens and it's a high time that
london
should
tell the truth to the international
community
could i please ask another question
i would like to ask whether all of the
members of the russian delegation got
the us visas not all of them
and we're expecting
the u.s party to comply with its
obligation as a hosting party
for the un
head quarters
and we expect additional for the visas
to all the members of other russian
delegations that will participate in uh
the
eu
in this session of our young general
assembly
al jazeera
are you present here
are you with what oh yeah uh good
afternoon
mario zaharova my name is
maria dreedy
this was some mistake about the name
my name
uh sorry for this error
if you let me we'll have two questions
uh the first one that we have an
information about an hour ago
that a special representative of russian
china pakistan
uh will
was meeting he today were meeting the
prem prime minister in kabul
do you have any additional information
on this respect what were the topics
this cost and the second uh question
about the election the european uh
commission critically
uh
stated its position on the elections it
said that it is was in the
atmosphere of intimidation and that the
elections were held without
international control how could you
assess such statement let me start with
the second question
we've already
commented
on the
statement of this
state department of the united states uh
let's now pass to
the european commission on the
assessment it has given to elections
in fact frankly speaking we see some
discrepancy here
yesterday we heard mr burrell's
statement
implying that they cannot give
assessment they couldn't give assessment
to
on the election because there were no
observers and then he issued another
another statement
saying that the election was not up to
the standards
it would be great if
the position uh was less ambiguous
so it is either
they could not
assess
the election
or
they can do this
since there were observers but they were
actually no observers so
it seems we go
this way and then that way
it's just impossible to continue like
that
where from do they get these facts
once again
we invited everyone to participate
as observers
during the
election parliamentary election in
russia
you have
seen
that
it was not clear what criteria was used
by the odihr
to connect
the
the visit of our country
to
the
russian election
there were some epidemiological
requirements
and we have taken into account the
requirements of the odihr
so invited 50 observers
from the odihr
but they didn't come
so if we take shock of
the developments around the odihr and
its participation as observers in the
election
they could have come to russia
and then
we heard that
different statements implying
that
the election could not be assessed since
there were no observers
so you
know what it led to
it was not new
this is
what falls under the constructive
uncertainty the time
coined by our partners
when they can change the trajectory
dependent on the circumstances and the
geopolitical situation
but this is not how we should work
so now to the facts
international observers
did come to russian regions and they
said the following
for example
home namatov the cis
had of
the head of the mission from the cis
said that they visited 623
polling stations and fixed no
irregularities and
they said that the level of organization
was very high
this is a real assessment that we've got
and as for the
phrase
implying that
there was no international control or
monitoring of the election in russia i
would like to give you the facts
almost
249 international observers
were in our country from 59 countries of
the world
and
10 international organizations
so
could you please tell me
who have given
someone the right to assess the presence
of these
experts
and
present it as the absence of
international control
the
colonial times were over and those were
the times when
people were divided into
first-class
uh citizens of second-class citizens
to the
slaves on those who own these slaves so
these times were gone
and
why
do people representing the european
body
representing the western civilization
um
show
that show contempt and disregard
for
other people
these are
senior officials and
they showed
themselves as
experts they were delegated by this that
country
uh and this about international
uh structure so
who has given
the right
to be so rude
and be
so dismissive
of the people from other countries
aren't they carried
far far away
they should have
re-read
the
conventions
and the
different rules of international law
that condemn
the division of
people
a few words about intimidation
what instrument have they used to
measure intimidation
what can they say about
the intimidation in their own country
when
they
when they try to
carry out their own political events
when they disperse people who take to
the streets
when they be journalists but if we are
serious about that
indeed it was the atmosphere of
intimidation although it wasn't not in
our country but in the european
countries
with
sanctions that would be imposed
after election
with the
continuous statements
about the results that wouldn't be
recognized
with the measures that would be taken
after the election this is actually the
atmosphere of intimidation
and
specific
people
and
european bodies were behind this
and as for european mass media it is a
different story it's indeed a propaganda
campaign
that they have
conducted
so this is it
and the second question was about
could you
remind me so it was about the meeting in
kabul
the special representative of russia's
president mr zamir kabulov
will take place we will participate in
the meeting and we will
inform you
of the developments
following the meeting right now we
cannot say anything since
the meeting is not over
thank you once again and sorry
sorry
no it's okay
news front out here
can you hear me good afternoon
yes
i have one question
about
kev's possible withdrawal from the minsk
agreement
mr rudenko
has stated
that there is a possibility that ukraine
will withdraw from the minsk agreement
and
give continues shelling
the territory of donbass
and does not comply with the agreements
and probably
after the kiev's withdrawal the
situation will become worse and
is there a possibility of russia's
burning cave back to
um
honoring its obligations
to settle the internal ukrainian
conflict
uh just to
add
a little bit i can say that
russia's position remains unchanged when
it comes to the settlement in donbass
this conflict should be solved through
peaceful means
on the basis of the means package of
measures that was
approved by
resolution 2202 by the
united nations security council and what
is needed is actually the political will
of kiev donetsk and lugansk and
the readiness to
have and maintain a direct dialogue in
line with the commitments that they have
assumed and unfortunately
kiev is not ready to do this on the
country
it strives to
subvert the minsk agreements and impose
its logics of settlement and
it has become more evident recently on
the 9th of august
the bill
called on the state policy of the
transition period
uh was brought
up to the consideration of verhovna
radha
which implies
the
which implies cleaning the area from of
of the forces that are not loyal to
kiev and instead of the special status
the language rights and amnesty for the
donbass citizens
and the powers for the
local authorities
in line with the minsk agreements
it
has a provision
on
imposing military and civil and
international
administration
which runs counter the means package of
measures and
it is only uh germany and france
that
intermediaries that are part of the
nomadic format that can bring you back
to honoring its international
obligations probably the united states
can also play its role
that can indeed influence kiev
the oc
can also make a difference since it's
also part of the contact group and the
united nations and the security council
that
uh approved the immense package of
measures and other countries can also
join as well as international bodies who
are not indifferent to the prospects of
the peaceful settlement of the conflict
and we on our part will continue to
insist that kiev should honor its
obligations and call down our partners
to
encourage the ukrainian authorities to
stop subverting the minsk agreements um
if you have
no more questions
we
would like to ask moscow post
we have a question about afghanistan
what have the consultations within the
seo uh given to define our position with
relation to taliban as you know the
situation in afghanistan
was on the top of the agenda of the seo
meeting that took place between the 16th
and the 20th of september
in dushanbe and it was a centerpiece of
the joint statement of the leaders of
the member states
they compared notes on the developments
in afghanistan and confirmed that they
intended to counter challenges and
threats arising from afghanistan and
they stressed how important it is to
coordinate
the anti-drug and counter-terrorism
efforts
the leaders of russia and other
countries
have defined
their position to
form an inclusive and representative
government taking into account the
interests of all the political forces of
this country and
our
line will
depend on whether the taliban is ready
to honor the obligations
pertaining to the state building
the seo and the csto member states are
on the same page implying that the u.s
and its allies should bear
responsibility for the past conflict to
restoration in afghanistan as a first
step to restore the humanitarian
situation and the future of afghanistan
depends on afghans themselves
as for the seo its member states
intended to
double down on
the work within the
contact group
asio afghanistan and to interact more
actively with this country
if there are no
questions
we move on deutsche balum are you here
yes alexander
deutsche
the central electoral commission
has previously
said that there were attacks
against the online voting uh could you
elaborate on that how many
attacks were there uh is there an
investigation going on
yes um
law enforcement agencies
and other relevant bodies
are dealing with these things it is not
the central electoral commission that
has to sort this out
it just
voiced its concerns about that and we
are ready to provide
the necessary information if you are
interested in that
and it seems that after the information
that you have that we have provided you
should be interested in this indeed we
have
a channel of communication apart from
all other diplomatic channels that we
have including embassies and
different types of consultations so we
have a special channel
to
sort out such things as
international information security
issues so we are ready to
answer
and respond to the requests from the
german side
of mr uh journal
um
are here
yes so we are here
we thank the minister of fornifiers of
russia and
foreign missions
who
allowed us to
cast
ballots and during the parliamentary
elections i would like to
stress that
many eu
citizens many citizens of other
countries do not have such a right such
an opportunity and
we felt that we are part of
uh russia so
may i interrupt you
yes we
did do that
we
allowed russians to exercise their right
it's
actually the obligation of
the state to create the necessary
conditions
for people to cast the vote and i'm glad
that russian citizens
appreciated that appreciated the
organization
which was a very high level
this is very important and i'm glad to
hear that
we are very attentive to
any criticism
this is actually why we
have been conducting information
communication work
and we try to respond to comments or
proposals
from you
but in this case
we have received quite positive
assessment of the work and thank you
very much for that
and i would like to thank
other compatriots
who
were
under quite hostile circumstances
manage to exercise their right
and so we thank them and you
for that
are you here
yes we are good afternoon
i have one question
how can you comment on
the accusations of
montenegro's president
he accused the russia of interfering
into the internal affairs of montenegro
well you know
i do not like trivial things i try to
avoid them
them this is what i learned at
the
department of international journalism
it's about
shifting
[Music]
responsibility
and the president of montenegro tries to
blame russia for the unrest
caused
by
the
abortive attack to thwart the
enthronement of a metropolitan
archbishop of
the black sea and the literal gionicki
in satania on the 5th of september
and they conclude
that the scheming of moscow and the
russian orthodox church were actually
the reason of the split
the cause of the split in the
montenegrin society
we accused of attempts to orchestrate
the processes inside the country and the
church itself
these ad hominem attacks
are indeed that we are it's something
that we regret
so
what i can say the group of the
montenegrin president who was behind the
events in satania
ostensibly continues
to
play out this church card
so
what form
as we understand they want to
wreak havoc to split the montenegrin
people into friends and foes
and escalate the situation in the
country to
bring back milo jokanovich
they are not hiding this it seems to me
but they try to sweep under the rug the
fact that
on the watch of the previous government
that was obsessed with the euro-atlantic
uh
church
choice
uh quite ignored uh the assessment of
the majority of the montenegrin
population
and this
dismissive attitude to its own people
was the source of all problems
rather than mythical interference from
the outside
no one has found russian hackers there
are there any
other questions yes
good afternoon
good afternoon tess
i have a question uh whether
the
meetings
for mr love with mr blinkings are
planned no such meetings are not being
planned
thank you if there are no questions
so i'm saying goodbye to you
till next meetings
and wish you good health
thank you
you